Okay so we've learned about support
Vector machines in their full generality
let's see how it works how they work on
a a simple example which is the heart
data where we've got a bunch of
variables not too many 10 or so
variables and and
we've the the there's two classes heart
disease or no heart disease and we use
the support Vector machines to classify
so in these two panels we show the
performance on the training data and
next slide we'll show on the test data
so what we are showing are Roc curves so
we've seen these before but just to
remind you
um
once we fit our function which is in
initially going to be a linear function
we Threshold at zero and that's the
decision boundary if if it's if the
function is bigger than zero we'll
classify to one Clause otherwise less
than zero to the other clause
and you'll make the number of Errors
you'll make some false positives and
false negatives here we actually look at
the false positives and the true
positives
well as you change the threshold you're
going to change the false positives and
and true positives
and what the ROC curve does is Trace out
the the false the true positives versus
the false positives as you change the
threshold and that gives you a curve
and if you think about it what you'd
really like is a curve that really hugs
this Northwestern Corner this one seems
to be doing pretty well
okay and a way of comparing classifiers
is to see which one gets closer to the
corner
okay so that's called The ROC curve the
name comes from an engineering term but
it's not really relevant in in terms of
how we use it today and remember the
so-called the AUC the area under the
curve is the the usual measure of of how
close the curve gets to the northwest
corner oh good point Rob so AUC
area under
the curve is a summary measure of of how
close you get to the cornea if the area
under the curve is one notice this is a
unit cube it means this curve exactly
gets into the corner
and there's a 45 degree line
um you should always be above the 45
degree line so the AUC will be between
0.5 and 1.
so in this left panel we've got this the
linear support Vector classifier that's
the red curve and we're comparing it to
linear discriminant analysis here which
is the blue curve and on the training
data they do pretty much the same maybe
the support vector's got a slight Edge
in in a few places
okay
in the left panel in the right panel
it's like in in the right panel We
compare the linear support Vector
classifier which is the red curve to the
svm using a radial kernel with different
values of gamma right
and you'll notice that
it's not monotone
so when gamma is 10 to the minus 1 we
seem to do really well
um when Gammas 10 to the minus 2
that's the green curve
we do we do worse than the red curve and
10 to the minus 3 even worse again
so remember the larger gamma the more
restrictive sorry the more Wiggly the
decision boundary and so this is ordered
in complexity so when gamma is large 10
to the minus 1 we're doing the best and
then as we as we decreased gamma we
start doing worse and worse and the
linear classifier sort of comes in in
between in the middle of that regime
which means gamma is another tuning
parameter for the support vector
classifier and just keep in mind what
they're telling us it's not really a
fair comparison in the right pattern
right because the the gamma smaller has
more complexity so it's going to fit
more so and this is a bigger yeah yeah
so that a training error comparison
isn't a fair comparison
right so we didn't do it yet but if we
made if we made uh gamma even much
bigger we'd probably get an area under
the curve of one right
so of course we know we should look at
test data and so here we put aside 80
observations as test observations and
fit the classifiers on the training data
and now compared to the now we look at
Roc curves on the test data
and again linear versus LDA it looks
like the the S support Vector classifier
does a little bit better just by a small
amount okay but notice that this Roc
curve is not as good as the previous one
on the training data because that was
overfitting a bit
and
in the right hand panel we look at the
different support Vector machines again
and now the one with the with the
biggest value of gamma actually does the
worst
so while it was
doing the best on the training data
actually does the worst on the on the
test data and yeah the linear support
Vector machine does pretty much the best
and and the most regularized
svm is with gamut 10 to the minus
can't see that number but three
um is is doing about the same
okay so these are tuning parameters and
we'd have to use all our usual tools for
for deciding if if we had to pick a
value for gamma we may use
cross-validation or validation data set
to pick it
as well as the the cost parameter C
so with a kernel we've got two tuning
parameters with a linear support Vector
classifier we've just got one which is C
okay so everything we've talked about so
far is for two classes separating
hyperplane two classes so what do we do
if we have more than two classes well
unfortunately things get a little bit ad
hoc here and so there's two general
approaches
and the ones called OVA
one versus all
it's a acronym
and so the idea is you fit K different
support to class support Vector machine
classifiers
each class versus the rest so you just
re-label all the other classes as a mega
minus one class and say the target
classes as class plus one
you further support vector classifier
and you do that with each of the classes
as being the plus one and all the others
being the minus one so that means you'll
fit K different classifiers
which means you'll have K different
functions and now when you come to
classify a new point you evaluate those
K different functions and you're
classified to the class which is the
largest
so that's the one approach
and the other approach is OVO
which is one versus one which means you
do all K choose two pairwise classifiers
so
if if K is for example 10 that means you
have to fit K choose two which is 45 45
classifiers right and so obviously that
gets bigger the number of classes gets
big
and so now you've got all these pairwise
classifiers and to classify a new Point
what you do is you evaluate every single
one of these classifiers
and you see which class wins the most
pairwise competitions
and that's the class to which you
classify
so you see mad hock and the the actual
mechanisms aren't quite as ad hoc as
they sound and so you can explain this
from a somewhat theoretical point of
view but that's what gets done in
practice one of these two the number of
classes is too large usually OVA
otherwise OVO tends to get favored
enough
okay we near the end of this section we
um we'll we'll end up by comparing
support Vector machines to logistic
regression so remember logistic
regression
um what what did solve classification
Problems by modeling the probabilities
of the classes
we support Vector machines we're
optimizing going directly for the
decision boundary they seem very
different it turns out they're not as
different as one might think
so if we write the linear function in
this form as we've done before
it turns out we can
we can rephrase the optimization problem
for the support Vector classifier in the
following form
now this is somewhat technical but
there's a loss function
between Y and f of x
summed over the observations so this is
similar to but not the same as a log
likelihood there's a penalty on the
coefficients it looks like it's a
quadratic penalty like a ridge penalty
here and there's a tune in parameter
Lambda
now this loss function is is a somewhat
strange Beast it's known as the hinge
loss and maybe it's better just to show
you a picture
so its primary argument is y times f of
x remember this is what we call now the
margin this is the quantity we'd like to
be positive
and the bigger it is the further a point
is away from its margin okay
so
this is the loss that we assign to that
quantity
in this formulation if it's bigger than
1 we sign zero loss so that's zero over
here but if it's less than one and
particularly if it goes negative it
means in all these regimes we're on the
wrong side of our margin
we pay an increase in linear loss
so that's called the hinge loss and if
you optimize this problem this this
Criterion with respect to the betas the
solution is equivalent to the sport
Vector machine well that's not obvious
right it's it's pretty hard
the derivation is not so easy really you
can't see just from looking no it's very
hard
um well it's not very hard but it's
quite hard
um to map this to the other one but
what's more important and it's not
necessarily that this is the way one
does it it's just illustrative
um because it allows us to compare to
logistic regression
because with logistic regression we also
fit in a linear function so the function
looks the same
remember there the linear function was
the loaded of the probability of class 1
versus class minus one in this case
so and for logistic regression we had a
log likelihood plus we could have a log
likelihood plus a ridge penalty
and the log likelihood is given by this
green curve over here
and you'll notice it looks very similar
it in this formulation it tapers off to
to be horizontal over here it asymptotes
to be linear over here but instead of
having the sharp corner over here it has
a a gentler corner
which means you can also think of
logistic regression as having a kind of
soft margin and and and that it focuses
more and points close to the margin then
points further away
so there's a lot of similarity between
logistic regression and support Vector
machines
and and if you want to learn more about
that you may want to look at our book
elements of statistical learning where
we go into this in a little bit more
detail it's one thing to add the fact
that the hinge loss has that corner is
what gives it the support Vector
property right the the the alphas that
are some of which are zero where's the
smooth loss doesn't have that property
you don't get support points good point
Rob and you may get pointers whose sort
of weight gets close to zero but not
exactly zero
okay so which to use support Vector
machine or logistic regression
we'll just sum up
um yeah so if the classes are nearly
separable the support Vector machine
tends to do better than logistic
regression and so does linear
discriminant analysis logistic
regression actually breaks down if the
classes are exactly separable
in that case you'd have to use some kind
of regularization with logistic
regression but support Vic that's a
regime where support Vector machines do
well
when the classes aren't separable where
there's somewhat there's quite a bit of
overlap logistic regression perhaps with
a ridge penalty or with a lasso penalty
tends to do better
and um and and it's more useful they
they similar the results will be similar
but it's more useful because it's
actually estimating probabilities for
you
um for non-linear boundaries
you can use kernel support Vector
machines and they popular you can use
the same kernels with logistic
regression and LDA as well but the
computations tend to be more expensive
and so in those scenarios support Vector
machines tend to be used
so here we are at the end of the session
Rob do you have anything to add yeah
well I was going to add about you know
there's sort of a a no-free lunch
principle with support Vector machines
we saw away with kernels to finesse the
the to get a solution essentially in
high dimensions for free but the one
price you pay is you you don't get a a
feature selection what you get for the
lasso for L1 penalties right where we
explicitly put a penalty on the features
and as a result a lot of the features
are set to zero with support Vector
machines one one disadvantage is it uses
all the features and and it it doesn't
easily select which features are
important so for high dimensional
problems uh that can be a drawback not
so much for the classification
performance but for the interpretation
of the solution
on the other point that Trevor mentioned
about about probability that's a really
important Point like if you're working
in a cancer diagnosis problem uh you
want you very often you you won't you
um you don't just want to classify but
you want to know the probabilities of
the the estimated class probabilities
because if something's got a probability
being cancer of 0.51 as opposed to 0.99
the classification is the same but the
the the implications in the actual
situation are very different so class
probabilities are very important and
support Vector machines don't provide an
easy way of getting those
the the community and support Vector
machines have tried to address these
problems with sort of post post our ad
hoc kind of add-ons something called
recursive feature elimination and also
they have ways of of actually getting
probabilities by fitting logistic
regressions after fit in support Vector
machines but we can do that directly
with with with for example um lassu
regularized logistic regression